Oh
hey guys what's up today we will be
drifting again to a Star Wars franchise
and discussing all the mobile
all-terrain walkers that serve in the
Galactic Republic the Galactic Empire
and the first-order but we won't be
including the Trade Federation droids
because we will be making another video
for them this list will be arranged in
ascending order of size and will include
all 26 of these walkers so have fun but
before you do do please subscribe and
hit the notification bell so here it
goes
number 26 the mark 1 automated Walker
the first entry to this list is the
robotic all-terrain personal transport
call the mark 1 automated Walker they
were armed with two blaster cannons and
a concussion grenade launcher they felt
the role of patrolling and heavy cavalry
from the New Republic era several
Marquand droid walkers were stationed on
Gallic fires ship during the Second
Battle of the Jedi Praxian these were
all annihilated in the ship's
instruction they were 2.5 metres tall
and had a top speed of 60 km/h number 25
the all-terrain exploration droid the
next on this list is another automated
all-terrain Walker called the a te D or
the all-terrain exploration droid it was
a model of exploration droid developed
in the collaboration between cyborg
Galactica and quadra Fiats
designed to assist in the exploration
and surveying of nearly discovered
planets it had a single-sided mounted
heavy blaster for armament it was two
and a half metres tall it also had good
balance and can easily traverse through
rough terrain number 24 the all-terrain
personal transport the third entry is
the 80 PT or the all-terrain personnel
transport and it is the first in this
list that is not a droid the walkers
were capable of reaching speeds of up to
60 km/h and could climb a 45 degree
angle with hydraulic at justice keeping
the unit balanced it was a light
anti-infantry Walker used by the
Galactic Republic and later the Galactic
Empire it was manufactured by Ratana
heavy engineering a subsidiary of the
kuat drive yards
number 23 the all-terrain recon
transport this one called the trt of the
recon transport or the Republic Scott
Walker is commonly seen two-legged
vehicle in service with the Republic and
was a model of recon Walker used mainly
during the Clone Wars by the advanced
recon force troopers
the ATR T's were usually used for a
variety of missions including ground
support police support civil defense and
post battle cleanup efforts it stands at
3.2 meters tall and carried one soldier
on top number 22 the all-terrain riot
control transport dat RCT was introduced
19 years before the Battle of Yavin and
served in the Galactic Republic the
Galactic Empire and the fell Empire it
was designed for use in cities and other
areas with large populations it had a
maximum speed of 90 km/h it is fitted
with two double medium blaster cannons
and suppression cannons this Walker
outsized the previous entry by three
merest as it stands around six meters
tall number 21 the all-terrain
experiment transport a highly effective
combat vehicle dat XT or the all-terrain
experiment transport was a predecessor
to the ATR T and the ATS D the 80 xt was
equipped with twin laser cannons mounted
under its chin and two long-range proton
mortar launchers this walker was a very
effective combat vehicle but it was
never mass-produced as its designers
were constantly improving its later
versions this walker stands at eight
metres tall and had a top speed of 75
km/h number 20 the all-terrain
construction walker although earlier
entries of this list were transports and
walkers and were designed for combat and
our troop delivery in the battlefield
this ATC w of the all-terrain
construction worker wasn't a combat
version even though it was based on the
famous Scout transport it sports two
legs and the ATC T was equipped with
small but powerful tractor beam
generators used to lift large building
materials for construction related tasks
it stands at eight point six meters tall
number 19 the all-terrain advanced
Raider this entry into the list is
called the all-terrain advance Raider
and also known as the light a TST are
also as a scout Walker and was a variant
of the all-terrain Scout transport used
by the Galactic Empire during the
Galactic Civil War the all-terrain
advanced Raider had a heavier armor than
the a TST for frontline combat even
though it was smaller but only armed
with a single laser cannon but on the
plus side it was faster these ATA ours
are the all-terrain advanced raiders
were all 9.04 metres tall and 4.5 metres
long number 18 the all-terrain Scout
transport the most famous and most well
known of the two legged ATS other Scout
transport are also called the Scout
Walker or a chicken Walker and this
vehicle was a lightweight bipedal Walker
used by the ground forces of the
Galactic Empire and also later by the
first order even though they use an up
fountain upgraded variant the Empire
used them for Swift reconnaissance and
troop support the ATS Ts were equipped
with two chin mounted MS fortuyn blaster
cannons and the range is two kilometres
these 80 STS were all 9.04 metres tall
and 4.5 metres long number 17 the
all-terrain missile platform the
all-terrain missile platform was a
walker used by the Imperial Army its
general appearance was similar to that
of the all-terrain Scout transport but
it was fitted with arms acting as
missile launchers and a chin mounted
rotary laser cannon that looked more
like a minigun its missile capabilities
made it heavier and more massive even
though it had the same dimensions as the
ATS d number 16 the all-terrain Kashuk
transport this next entry also shares
the same dimensions as the a TMP and the
a TST being 4.5 meters long and 9.04
metres tall the all-terrain Kashuk
transport was an all-terrain Scout
transport Varian built by the quad drive
yards this walker was equipped with
large anti personal net guns on each
side of the cockpit area and an array of
other weaponry the Walker was used on
the planet
to more effectively deal with the
continual rookie insurgency at number 15
we have the all-terrain defense turret a
bigger and more effective bipedal Walker
used by the Galactic Empire this entry
was a slow vehicle due to the size of
its main cannon which fight a massive
shot that exploded on impact but while
firing it was rendered immobilized it
was vulnerable to anti vacant weapons as
a result of its light armor the first
footage of the all-terrain defense
turret was shown in the solo a Star Wars
story official trailer on April 8 2018
this walk is a bit taller at 9.11 metres
tall the number 14 we have the
all-terrain defense board the next one
on this long walking list is the
all-terrain defense spot or the a TDP
which was a bipedal Imperial Walker
manufactured by the quad drive yards
prior to and during the Galactic Civil
War they were driven by the Imperial
combat drivers this walker was a
successor to the smaller ATR t as it
stands almost three and a half times
taller at eleven point six meters tall
even though it ranks less than the next
one the reason is that its overall mass
way lesser than the upcoming rank number
thirteen the all-terrain tactical
enforcer this walker outranks the
previous even though it is shorter than
the last entry simply because height
doesn't always mean bigger it was a
multi-purpose military ground Walker
used by the Galactic Republic during the
Clone Wars they boasted six legs that
could be magnetized six laser cannon
turrets located along the body of the
Walker and a heavy projectile masked
driver cannon on top this beast was 22
metres long and almost 10 metres tall
Namah thrust the all-terrain attack poor
the all-terrain attack bot also referred
to the 80 AP self-propelled artillery
walker or the 80 AP was a small try
pedal Walker manufactured by the quad
drive Fiats
and was developed from the 80 PT the 80
AP had an angular hull that was situated
above to multi-jointed legs and had a
smaller retractable third like the 80
ApS primary weapon was a powerful
long-range heavy mass driver cannon
located in the forward hull this wok is
11 metres tall number 11 the all-terrain
anti-aircraft this next entry has a
length of 18 meters long and we had to
research and estimate its height to be
around 13 to 14 meters tall da taa or
the all-terrain anti-aircraft had four
stubby legs and lizard looking
locomotion along with the low profile on
most models the only weapon was a turgid
flag board
capable of firing several types of
orleans the walker saw action during the
Galactic Civil War where it was used
against aircraft but was useless against
any ground vehicles number 10 the
all-terrain heavy hauler this one is
neither a combat or a troop carrier
version of the Walker it was
manufactured and seen first serving the
first author during the Battle of cried
also known as the truck Walker two were
used during the Battle of crate to
Tucker superlaser siege cannon towards
the resistance base although their
primary purpose was to top and pull
massive ground weapons they were far
from defenseless near unusual
multi-legged design comparable to
crustaceans and insects provided immense
power
they were 29.57 meters long and fourteen
point two nine meters tall
number nine the all-terrain open
transport the all-terrain open transport
or dat ot was an eight-legged walker
design for the transportation of
infantry used by the Grand Army of the
Republic during the Clone Wars
it was deployed during the Battle of
Felucia towards the end of the war this
Walker was seen in the third movie of
The Revenge of the Sith it was seen
transporting clone soldiers into dense
forested areas this Walker stands at
fourteen point three meters tall and is
available and effective vehicle of the
Empire number eight d all-terrain
dune walker at last the first amongst
the four-legged 8080 variants and this
is the dune Walker it was a modified
version of the all-terrain armored
transport used by the Galactic Empire it
was specifically designed to serve on
planets with deserts and hot climates
all terrain armored transport were often
modified to be more effective in certain
missions and equipped with special
components for specific environments
the dune Walker was 220 meters long and
15 point 5 meters tall
number 7 the all-terrain armored
transport the famous all-terrain armored
transport or the 8080 Walker also known
as the Imperial Walker was a backbone
and a major part of the galactic empires
cavalry this basic version brings with
it a vast amount of firepower and was
also heavily armored the 8080 was
arguably the most feared and effective
land vehicle in the Imperial Army it
stands 20 meters long and 20 2.5 meters
tall 7 meters longer than a dune Walker
and number six we have the all-terrain
armed with heavy transport coming up
next is the deli armored version of the
8080 and this one is called the a tah T
or the all-terrain armored heavy
transport it is more heavily armored
than its basic variant but stands at the
same height and length but I'm betting
that it weighs more and hence ranks
above the others it is also twenty two
point five meters tall but fits the part
of the heavy cavalry and has won many
battles due to its armor which is
resistant to small arms fire and even
medium sized arms and number five we
have the first-order
all-terrain armored transport although
also terms the basic variant of the 8080
the first-order version features
increased armor and a boarding ramp
under its chin in place of the heavy
laser cannons instead its primary
weapons were mounted on the sides of its
heads to first all the 88 es were
deployed during the Battle of cried it
was manufactured by the kuat and tralala
drive yachts and was longer at 24 metres
long but the same height at 20 2.03
meters tall and at number four we have
the all-terrain iron cannon dat IC
resembled the star and 8080 design
except half of its structural body blaze
was dedicated to supporting a massive
iron cannon the Galactic Empire
converted a small number of its 8080
walkers into mobile ion cannons which
became known as all-terrain iron cannon
walkers they were 26 metres long and a
bit taller at 23 metres tall
number three the all-terrain armored
cargo transport the 88th CTR the
all-terrain armored cargo transport was
another variant of the 8080 and was
deployed at major imperial construction
projects such as shipyards and sprawling
research installations even though they
were not built for combat they were
still capable of posing a formidable
threat to infantry as discovered by
rebel troopers during the Battle of scar
if they were 35 metres long and almost
32 metres tall number two the
all-terrain mega caliber 6 the ATM 6r
also known as the gorilla walker or the
first-order heavy assault walker was a
mobile heavy artillery walker used by
the first order in the years following
the collapse of the Galactic Empire and
the capture of destruction of most of
its industrial capabilities by the New
Republic the first order sought a
successor to the original Imperial
all-terrain armored transport and this
eventually led to the development of the
ATM 6 and voila here comes the BBS that
stands almost 41 metres long and more
than 36 metres tall and at the number
one spot comes the self-propelled heavy
artillery turbo laser this spot goes to
an unlikely candidate and it was a
self-propelled artillery Walker this
Walker was a modular heavy artillery
unit used by the Grand Army of the
Republic during the Clone Wars and by
the Galactic Empire
afterwards it had 12 legs that serve as
a mobile support structures and they
were deployed directly from acclimated
glass assault ships the SPH a walker
chassis served as the basis for a number
of different weapons platforms though
the best chronicle version was the turbo
laser this monster dwarves the others in
length being 140 metres long but are
shorter than the gorillas being at only
20 point 6 meters tall anyways this
brings us to the end of the video do
like share and subscribe for more
related content and hit the notification
bell for actual notifications